[Music]
of this episode of travel tears I'm
taking Caroline to Utah Olympic Park but
we're gonna go extreme tubing and I'm
taking Jo to mystic hot springs to soak
in a bathtub filled with natural spring
water come join us on our adventures on
this episode of Travel dares
welcome to travel dares I'm Joe and I'm
Caroline and we're here in Salt Lake
City Salt Lake City is home to some of
the most beautiful views in the world
every place we visited so far has been
so unique and different and I can't wait
to see what Salt Lake City has to offer
let the fun begin okay go for the gold
[Music]
let's go
golde reminds me of the Olympics you
know maybe we're gonna have a little bit
of a competition
I know Caroline's trying to get better
with thrill rides and I feel that this
is gonna bring out for inner daredevil
all right Caroline I want you to remove
your blindfold we are going for the 2002
Winter Olympic Games Utah decided to
build ski jumps into the side of the
mountain that you see behind me and this
is what we've turned it into today
there's only a handful of ski jumping
facilities around the nation we're one
of them and we're the only one that does
extreme tubing oh my gosh we just got to
the top of the hill and look at this you
[Music]
the gold medalist I can do this
[Music]
five seconds is serious thing in the
world but like once you toss that it is
fun so it's very intimidating the first
time you get in a - but as soon as
you're going down and you picked up
speeds of up to 50 miles an hour it's
the most exhilarating feeling you'll
have here at Utah Olympic Park
[Music]
again yeah we offer unique experiences
that you can't find anywhere else and
when someone does that for the first
time they always leave with a smile on
the face you know this is such a
historical place I feel like so many
people have achieved their dreams here
alright so just things about Salt Lake
couldn't get any better
here's your clip oh right let's see what
we got here um time to clean up oh we're
gonna clean something oh okay clean up
Carolina this is the most cryptic clue
you have given me on this show yeah I
couldn't even guess I have no idea where
we're going when we were in New York
I took Joe to his first spa and now
we're gonna take it up a notch and
experience an all natural hot spring in
the Utah mountain
[Music]
they're now squat down just a little bit
and watering and dip your right hand
down hey whoa what is this hot water
take it black hole up Joe what is what
is this we are at one of Utah's most
iconic Hot Springs
oh sweet look how amazing this is
Oh beautiful
[Music]
the water's been coming up out of the
ground here for a long time it's a good
water temperature it comes out of the
ground at 168 degrees it cools as it
travels we keep the pools and the tubs
between about a hundred and hundred and
ten degrees and every time people get
into the hot springs they get this
tremendous sense of relaxation and
relief it's something you have to
experience you know pictures and my
words only go so far it's just a great
way to connect with the earth with
yourself
and with the others there
[Music]
it's like getting a massage from the
planets it's nice because it's just like
you know we're out here it's just like
doing its thing it just feels like
you're like one with nature I feel like
everywhere you turn you see something
gorgeous I mean just look at this view
this is the perfect way to end our trip
to Utah I'm so glad we came here
right
[Music]
Caroline what an unforgettable day
exploring Utah I already know that I had
a blast extreme to being but what do you
think you actually totally got into it
you looks like pretty much land up the
hill you're the first one down you're
all about it and for those reasons I'll
give you a five all right Caroline
moment of truth
how'd I do Joe you're so relaxed today
and you're really enjoying the view and
I think you're really connected with
nature and those three things add up to
a five star rating yes
we've been to five amazing destinations
so far and it's been a fun way to
explore the country next up Portland
[Music]